it is a welcome coincidence that some of
those who live down this road remember
the last time it happened
Cynthia is expecting a more toned down
celebration to the one she watched aged
23. nonetheless she'll be tuning in from
the crack of dawn oh it was lovely you
know the queen was so pretty
she was a nice age you know they'll be
so very different there was more Pomp
and ceremony in the 1953 one don't you
think so you're probably right Ken says
it will be nostalgic but not in all the
ways he'd like I suppose you know I've
heard a lot not younger I'm not saying
another I would I would like to bring
down the mouth and to watch some old
people coming together we'll get to see
Ken two British monarchs being crowned
in your lifetime what's that like
I'm getting old
they have a semblance of what to expect
but many of us simply don't
thank you
the children of Lorne Primary School in
Derby are full of expectation and
anticipation it's like symbolizing a new
era for the country and it's everyone's
just coming together as a country to
watch it I can spend time with my family
and watch the king get crowned for the
country to celebrate Tim basically
getting crowned so that's what I'm
really looking forward to
at least they've got the necessary
attire and plenty of enthusiasm
seamstresses have been helping the
nation get ready their machines haven't
stopped churning out the decorations in
the last two months we have produced 100
kilometers of bunting which is probably
about two or three times the amount of
bunting we would do in any one year and
that's just purely for the coronation
the coronation of one man big smile all
eyes may be on the capital
but much of the nation too will also be
better Blue Ash Sky News in
Cambridgeshire